hey everybody welcome to the podcast
very excited because
my guest today is mary kane the mary
kane the track and field athlete who
by high school had established herself
as the fastest girl
in a generation the mary kane who at 17
became the youngest american ever to
make a world championship track and
field team
that mary kane for whom olympic glory
seemed a foregone conclusion
until that is she joined nike's
elite oregon project under alberto
salazar
within that culture her body ultimately
collapsed her running career behind it
and for a couple years thereafter she
just
kind of disappeared until
november of 2019 that is when mary
broke her silence on what happened and
why
telling her story by way of a video
op-ed in the new york times
entitled i was the fastest girl in
america
until i joined nike that video went
crazy viral it resulted in a groundswell
of global support for mary and open the
door
to a broader ongoing conversation around
the toxicity
that pervades female athletics and the
means by which we can
construct a better future for women and
girls in sports
not content to merely tell her story or
just
get back to running but to actually do
something
make a real difference mary just
announced the launch of
atlanta a new new york city-based elite
running team and community non-profit
it's an endeavor that she leads as ceo
with the dual mission
of promoting running community
inclusivity and diversity
and rewriting the rule book on
professional women's athletics
today we get into all of it her story is
powerful
this one is kind of a wild emotional
ride and i'm really proud to help
share it so thanks for watching hit that
subscribe button
and here we go this is me rich roll by
the way
and mary kane
[Music]
it's so nice to meet you sorry you got
the wrong
address got a little bit lost but you're
here i've been waiting for this for a
long time
i've been texting all our mutual friends
telling them how excited i am to meet
you so thanks for doing this yeah
absolutely i mean i'm just excited to be
able to travel to la
like this has been such a fun little
long weekend is it your first time
traveling since the whole
shebang um about a month ago i had
traveled to park city
um and that had been one of those trips
that were
cancelled and you had to book within a
year and all of a sudden april was
rolling around and we're like
i guess we're still going um so that was
my first time on a plane so this was my
second right
right right what was the vibe um i don't
know i felt like it was
it was good in that like everybody's
wearing their masks everybody
seemed to be taking all the rules
seriously and
you know i was on a delta flight so we
were like as spaced as we almost could
be
um so yeah i found if anything it like
felt pretty safe and right you know it
that adds to the excitement maybe
and what's the vibe in new york does it
feel like it's coming back
or yeah this whole idea that new york
city is dead
yeah it's not dead oh man if you guys
follow the real estate market in new
york city it's crazy right
everybody's yeah and bananas i think new
york's gonna have this crazy renaissance
maybe not right away but in the next
year um mary wittenberg
um is like this is like the 1970s and
we're going to have this like
big renaissance of like you know
cultural influence now again and
just 50 years later where you go through
a really tough time and it and it
resurges
and i think you see that even in um the
recent
announcements about like you don't have
to wear masks outside anymore and like
certain things shifting um you all of a
sudden feel this energy of like oh
i want to come back and i think even
people who left are starting to get like
a little antsy of like
what am i going to miss out on maybe i
need to come back
well when summer hits and you get those
nice warm nights
in new york i think it's going to be
like the summer of love
oh yeah i mean i'm right near central
park too so i probably have like
at times a skewed view of like how many
people are out and about
but gosh if i go for my evening run and
it's like
60 degrees i can barely get around the
reservoir some days because you're just
like
everybody wants to be out right now
right it's cool
it's exciting right and it's fun even
from the running perspective of like yes
you have that moment where you're
hurdling a kid in central park and
you're like this maybe could have been
better
but in general like the more people are
out the more energy that is and then you
feed off of it yeah you feel it
you feel it you get that like surge of
vitality that only new york can deliver
yes absolutely because it's just so
dense and so
diverse and there's so many people like
kind of following their own dreams and
passions and
as a result i just feel like there's
inspiration everywhere you turn
yeah yeah you don't get that here that's
why i feel like i have to visit
like a couple times a year to like get
that feeling and then come back like
renewed and exhausted yeah yeah fair i
mean the thing i
will say and i'm you know like born and
raised in the new york city area i
grew up in the suburbs right outside of
the city and so i've probably always had
like
a bit of a biased view um but nowhere
else in the country is a city
like we are the only place that is like
truly an urban environment
um there's no sprawl in the same way
like we have suburbs but
like the actual density of like each
block
is just like you know like maybe chicago
could hold their own but
um sometimes even like my friends and
co-workers in boston will be like kind
of comparing boston to new york and i'm
like oh
that's cute you're a small town well
the thing about i mean new york city is
my favorite place to go running like it
even though i love the trails and the
nature and all of that like when you go
running in new york city
every time you go outside your door it's
an adventure and you're gonna see
all kinds of stuff and sometimes i just
i love the park i like you know i like
riverside i like all the all the typical
places that you run but sometimes i like
to just run the streets and not have any
agenda about which way i'm going to turn
just based on the lights or whatever and
just go down random streets and
just take it all in and you're so
there's so much
stimuli everywhere you look that you
lose track of like how long you've been
running and i don't know i just i love
it
oh i completely agree i've always said
that new york city is the best
like running city in the world and in
and when i
use the word city there i'll i'll give
other you know places a chance to
claim that that's so kind of you you
know
yeah now you're getting snobby yeah
exactly
um but i think for me it's like one the
fact that it's the only
um it's one of the only places in the
world where there's such a vibrant
amateur set up where there's true teams
and there's competitions weekly and
we have new york road runners there who
can help put on um
just like races week after week after
week and i think since there's such a
like
organized ability to participate in
sports post-collegiately
um particularly running it just creates
this dynamic too where like
you never are in central park alone like
it doesn't matter what time it is if
it's 5 a.m
i'm shocked by the number of people who
will be out like in giant groups
having way too much fun even though it's
5 a.m and yeah i'm not normally a 5 a.m
runner but the times it
has happened i'm like really i think
carried by that
energy the running culture is just
interwoven
with the urban culture of new york and
it's crazy when you go
into the park and you see people running
and you're
and it's like wow these are like real
runners like people you're like that
guy's legit
yeah some dude and you're like he i
don't know what he's training for but
like whoever's racing against that guy
i feel sorry for you know like true
elites everywhere you go and
you know everybody else at the same time
like it's just it's kind of a cool
beautiful thing yeah and i think that's
what's exciting about new york too where
it it spans like kind of from
the highest end professionals to like
people who are just starting running
and i don't feel um there's almost
this setup where it's like in order to
join a team you have to have
like x y and z standards if anything
it's like so many of the groups are
catering more to this like community
environment
and just being inclusive and um like
welcoming people who are maybe this is
their first time ever stepping out to go
for a run
and to me that's just important because
i think elsewhere it can become
maybe more intimidating to join a team
uh because like you only run if you're
this quote-unquote
runner which i hate when people say that
i'm like if you run
you're a runner like you don't there's
no threshold i'm not asking for your
splits
um and i think in new york we kind of
have that mindset of like if you run
you're a runner
um and elsewhere can get a little bit
more um
maybe people kind of hedge like and
they're like ah maybe not good enough to
be on that team they seem pretty serious
so i'm not gonna you know intimidation
right well spoken
like a true community manager what's
your title with tracksmith something
like that like yeah
vice president of community or something
yeah i'm the new york city community
manager
that's so funny right you have a job
title i know
i actually well i'm it's kind of crazy i
have like three job titles now
um new york city community manager for
tracksmith i'm
a virtual coach specialist for new york
road runners where i work
part-time and now i'm ceo of an
organization i'm starting
atlanta atlanta we're going to talk
about that before we do that though
um i went running with our mutual bff
alexi
pappas the other day and uh
it's funny like i didn't really think
about whether you guys were
friends or not i guess i just assumed oh
yeah they must they must know each other
but i didn't realize the depth
of your friendship and how far back it
goes until i read that beautiful
runners world article which is amazing
everybody should check that out i'll
link it up in the show notes
you guys go way back and we're of course
chatting and she's telling me about her
movie and
all kinds of stuff and then she but she
knew that you were coming on the show
which i was like oh cool you know that
and
she's just telling me a little bit i was
like what should i ask her
what should we talk about and she was
like well everybody you know obviously
wants to know about the thing
right which we're going to have to talk
about because this isn't an exclusively
running oriented podcast so there's
going to be people who don't know that
story
um but also this sense
of of you not wanting to
like understanding people want to hear
that story but not wanting to dwell in
the past and
and and really you know being more
focused on
all the great things that you're doing
now that you're doing so well
and i was like cool and after our run
then alexi texted me
because she had additional thoughts of
course she said
right of course and she said mary's
doing great but there's always grieving
to do
and i think she's doing a phenomenal job
of observing and allowing that grief
while also growing up and crafting a
life she wants
before her own eyes so it's both she's
great and she knows she has
all that inside that's amazing alexis
just has a way with words that i feel
the number of times after we've had
like a 90-minute conversation over the
phone and
we we say our goodbyes like five minutes
later she ends up sending a paragraph
that just like
literally makes me tear up about like
how much our friendship means to her
or um just like some inspirational thing
based on
like a different topic that we had
talked about over the course of the
conversation
um and i always feel my reply is
probably not as eloquent
well she's she said you know she was
gonna go get her phd in poetry you know
and her book
i mean not everybody can write a book
like that it's quite something
it was beautiful i mean i was one of the
first people who got to read it
um and i i think i finished it in like
two days
and i just the whole time would be
texting her stuff and some of the
stories even though we are very good
friends
i didn't know and a lot of it was
like on that personal level for her
where many people who were very close to
her didn't have that full
picture yeah um and being able to like
get to be one of the first people to see
that and experience that and then
talk to her about it um felt felt very
special
and conversely she was not aware of all
the things that you were
going through at the time it's that
thing where
you're in that pain and you silo
yourself off even from your closest
friends because
you guys were close back then but both
neither of you were really communicating
with each other
on that deeper level about what you were
enduring privately
yeah absolutely and i think in many ways
the reason we are both very vocal now
about mental health depression and the
need to
talk about it and the need to seek help
and lean on other people
is because we reflect on our own
journeys which
have shockingly overlapped like even on
the year to year where
it's like wow 2016 what happened that
year
and as you kind of look um i think as we
look back there's this ability to see
you know maybe if we could have should
have would have
um and leaned on each other things would
have gone a little differently
and that's not to say you can talk
yourself out of depression that's not to
say you can talk yourself
out of a mental health struggle but at
least being able to know somebody else
is going through it
and maybe working together to find the
resources to get us help
um you know could have saved us both
sooner
and knowing that makes me always think
how can i help somebody else
take that step earlier yeah well i think
alexi writing her book and you sharing
your story in the way that you have been
doing
is you know the path forward because
that gives other people
the comfort and the you know empowerment
required to share something that you
know
privately they feel like maybe they
can't
right i know you're a big renee brown
fan
yes and she's all about that like can
you summon the courage to be vulnerable
on that level
yeah and i think you know for me it's
always come back to and
i i just say this in that um
you know as honest way as i can that for
me it always was like yes this is going
to help me in my own healing journey
completely um if i share then it's kind
of like
putting sometimes putting words out
there can like
create truth in a way that thoughts
can't quite do and it's the same reason
why like during a workout sometimes you
have to like verbalize i got this
just like feel that extra energy and so
that kind of maybe selfish reason is
part of the reason i shared my story
but so much more so it was it's scary
to realize that so many mental health
injuries as the lexi would call them
are something that even if you have it
you can't recognize in the same way
um and i think physical injuries
especially as runners we can relate to
this
like who hasn't run through an injury
for like
two weeks longer than they should have
because they convinced themselves it was
something else or something they could
work through or
et cetera et cetera but issues that
relate to
mental health i feel like since you
can't physically see it
since you can't get that mri diagnosis
and even since it's harder to find
medical professionals who are always
going to
really know how to help you as an
individual
i think it's just harder to sometimes
recognize what you're actually going
through
and so the big reason that i came
forward and i know
the big reason that alexi is sharing her
story is because
if it can help one other person put a
name
to what their experience is then the
ability for them to seek help
is so much higher yeah um and i know for
me personally like i
always kind of explain to people that i
knew
in 2016 that i had like
forms of disordered eating um but i
didn't know
why i didn't know what that kind of
deeper darker
depression was underneath that was
predisposing me to have these tendencies
and it wasn't until i was able to
actually like
realize that emotional abuse by the
hands of a coach
was what was like always holding me back
from like truly
both getting the help that i needed but
also knowing how to get the help that i
needed
um it just made all those use beers
before not
not pointless but not as successful as
it could have been yeah
yeah fruitful and positive and all those
you know
like great things and instead it wasn't
until 2019
and like really around the time that i
was sharing the story um
that i was suddenly able to like really
get help well you can point
you can you can kind of identify a
couple
primary reasons for that i mean first of
all there was there
of course there are are women who have
spoken publicly about reds and
disordered eating and sport and all that
all the like but perhaps not on the
scale with which your
story seemed to connect i mean it was so
crazy viral
when the video was published and i want
to talk about that but at the same time
from a systemic point of view you were
on this team
that you know on paper looked like
everything was dialed in and all the
support that any
professional athlete at the elite level
would ever need to
succeed including quote unquote you know
performance psychologists and
nutritionists that turned out like
weren't that at all right so
you can't really you know be too hard on
yourself because being as young as you
were
and not knowing you know that not being
able to point to
examples out in the world that would
help you kind of map out where you were
at and not having
the internal support and the kind of you
know
situation the dynamic that was at play
at
the oregon project at the time like you
were kind of left to fend for yourself
with
all this yeah and i think now today as i
sit here i totally recognize that
and i think the tough thing is and i
think why
in so many ways the video went more
viral than i had expected
um is because logically
that's true but emotionally
it can take years for somebody to
recognize that they're not at fault
and i think a lot of that is just
societally we
have almost created this like horrible
and toxic perspective that all mental
health
um is somehow a personal failing and it
kind of goes back to that calvinistic
like you know where you are is because
of like you know who you are in a way um
and i hate thinking and it's horrible
um but i think that really kind of
filters into
our society at large and as a result you
know
what what's really difficult for i think
a lot of young people is that when
you're
in these really like toxic and horrible
and abusive situations
um as you're breaking down you start to
see this quote
truth in what they're saying because you
are like yeah i am super emotional i'm
crying every single day like
maybe i am the problem because i'm the
one crying
we're like yes you know i'm the one that
they're telling is overweight
so like that must be something i'm doing
wrong
and i think it's so easy to get
therefore into this really toxic
self-blame perspective um and that's not
to say there are things
i look back and and like you know oh
maybe
like had i just known to be more
confident or do this
you know you you always kick yourself
you know um
in some ways but i think i've made peace
with my past
in a way that um you know being able to
share publicly and
almost develop this relationship with
thousands and millions of people
who were able to watch that and kind of
see themselves in my story
is both really tragic but also beautiful
in that healing process of knowing
you're not alone right right
we should probably sort of establish the
terrain that we're talking about for
people that are watching or listening
who who aren't familiar with the
trajectory of your story and how it
became like a viral moment
so why don't we just spend a few minutes
talking about your background so you
grow up
outside of new york city bronxville you
run in high school
you're crushing it you're breaking all
these like high school records it's
absolutely insane like winning high
school titles
and you essentially go pro right out of
high school
um and start working with alberto
salazar you move to
portland when you're like 17 16.
yeah and that's where things start to
get
a little bit janky right so so talk a
little bit about
the lead up to to moving to portland and
kind of the early days of working with
alberto at
the nike oregon project yeah so i first
met him the beginning of my junior year
um
and i still lived in new york i was
still a high school junior
and we had this long distance
relationship
my junior and senior year during which
i ended up qualifying for the world
championships at the end of my junior
year
signing a professional contract with
nike um
that my fall senior year and then going
on to
have like a really incredible senior
year season and he's he's coaching you
like remotely at that point
yeah yeah and like there are times where
maybe we're at the same meet together
or i travel out to like that summer
and that i competed on the world stage i
traveled out and was kind of like with
their team for maybe like three or four
weeks or something
but it was always these kind of like
little moments um
and it was always so much fun right
because you have your coach
um on the ground with me in new york
john henwood
who was kind of that buffer i had my
parents there who were always that kind
of buffer
between me and the team um but
everything sounded great
and everything was going great in high
school
i was working with this now i have to
say
quote support psychologists um you know
like there was more positivity and
everything was kind of like oh this is
fun
um and then i ended up after my indoor
season senior year developing a stress
reaction
in my shin and that was kind of the
moment that things
changed and i think truthfully and just
like at least how i kind of look back on
it i think having a little bit of time
off my body started to develop like a
little bit
right nothing nothing like you know i
didn't all of a sudden
gain like 10 pounds or anything like
that it wasn't something you could even
necessarily visually see
but physically i could tell there was
some sort of changes starting to
happen because i'm all of a sudden at
you know the end of that
high school you know going into college
years this is when a lot of women start
to develop
and so all of a sudden weight started to
become a conversation
in a way that in the past it hadn't
really been
um and it would kind of start off small
of being like oh
you know you're cross-training you have
to be more conscientious of your weight
and
um it just kept building and building
and building
so by the time um like i was kind of in
full swing
of the outdoor season i ended up coming
in second
at the us championships ran a 406
and was feeling really good and really
positive
but i kept being told that i couldn't go
to europe that year to race
because i wasn't fit enough from alberto
yes and it was like this kind of like
you're not fit you're not fit you're not
fit
and i didn't like i kind of was like i
came in the second at the usc
there's one person maybe a little bit
more fit than me literally
yes um and so i just didn't really get
it
and i ended up racing at the world
junior championships
and the day before the race i was told
to do two
100 meters all out and and i was told to
break 13 seconds for the hundred
and i ended up running 12-5 for both of
them so i didn't
think anything of it besides the fact
that it's kind of weird to like do
all-out sprints the day before a race
but
um after the race um
alberto kind of that week i was like hey
i'm world junior champion
i'm second at usa is like let's dive in
like let's go to europe let's do what we
did last year
and and that was when it finally became
clear that this
fitness was about weight um and
it was because he told me that the
reason he had me do those hundreds the
day before
is that he wanted to have the talk the
day before the race
that i was too heavy and
he wanted me to do those hundreds
because he didn't think i would be
physically capable of breaking 13
because he thought i was too big to do
it um
but then you go 12-5 and he didn't eat
his lunch after that
no he still told me like after the race
that
um even though i did that it it's clear
i'm not
like i'm not skinny enough to travel
um so of course i'm you know
just graduated high school literally
moved out to oregon
right after uh winning world juniors
and rather than traveling to europe we
decide i'm going to stay in portland
over the summer
and i'm going to get fit aka lose weight
and you know there was kind of this idea
that if i lost
one pound per week i could get down to
113 pounds
to race at fifth ave and therefore i
might be competitive
um and granted again i came in second uk
so in retrospect i should have just
thought
what the heck um but you know this is
hypothetically the best coach in the
world sure and how
i mean we're gonna dive deeper into the
whole weight thing but
on some level like when you when you
tell that story it almost feels like
a way in which he can exert greater
control like is it a control issue as
much as it is a weight issue because
as long as he can lord that over you
then he can kind of be the puppeteer
yeah absolutely and and i think we
recognize that now
in retrospect with other kind of
behaviors that happened
um like when i was in high school um
he communicated and all the team
communicated a lot
with my parents right to be like after a
good workout
there would be this like wow mary did
awesome so cool congrats
um and it felt like this really kind of
like family
team dynamic and everything's just so
positive um as soon as i went out to
portland
like all communication with my parents
stopped
and what happened was that i
after um world juniors as the like
dedicated athlete that i was who
yes again in retrospect i was racing at
this really high level
but to me i'm you know i've been top 10
in the world like i'm trying to be a
world champion
you know that's that's kind of like my
end game so when somebody's telling me
you're not fit enough
well yeah i was second at usa's maybe
maybe that's top 20 in the world and i'm
constantly pushing so i did what i was
told
and and i lost you know probably like
six to seven pounds because i think i
was about 120 at the time
um like scaled down to 113.
um and that was when disordered eating
started
and how was your performance that year
oh it ended up like i mean now i look
back i'm like wasn't that bad but it was
horrible compared to the years before um
but what happened was i
um after fifth ave i didn't race
that well i came in eighth i was and i
didn't look good
um my parents saw me because we were
back in new york and
truthfully they had felt a little like
distanced from me and from the program
and it was kind of this weird last like
two months of
um being a little bit ghosted um
and my mom saw me and was just like you
don't
look good you look pale like dark
circles under your eyes what's
kind of going on um and i
you know admitted that like i've been
really working to lose weight like
i've been told i you know was too heavy
to travel
and my parents naturally got really
upset about that because they're like
what are you even talking about you
raced great like why is that a
conversation and
a phone call was had with the you know
um i'll call him high performance coach
on the team
right this person sort of held himself
out to be
a psychologist but it turns out was not
indeed a psychologist
yes exactly right i thought he was a
medical professional and
therefore like treated our conversations
as such
um but i afterwards
got in big trouble for telling my
parents
um about like my struggles with weights
and everything
and i got this big lecture which
continued
throughout that year um where if i ever
kind of like
maybe told my parents something that i
was uncomfortable with or
um you know whether it was about like
taking birth control or an inhaler or
thyroid medication or whatever it was um
if i told them that then i would get
yelled at
because i had to be an adult i had to be
a professional you can't go crying to
your parents
you know all this sort of stuff and you
know as an 18 year old who's at college
you know like most freshmen yeah that's
great i mean you're 18 years old
that's a crazy control thing right
you're 18 years old how dare you
tell your parents what's going on in
your life yeah and what's interesting
about that
is the fact that salazar's
defense or rebuttal in the wake of
you know you coming out and sharing your
story is that
he's claiming that he was in constant
communion with your parents and talking
to them about weight stuff your dad's a
doctor right
so is that just not true no it sounds
like from your point of view that didn't
happen at all
so when i was in high school again they
talked a lot like there was a lot of
this like back and forth like
you know emailing calling like super
positive right
i move out to portland all of that ends
and the only time my parents are hearing
anything
is if it's coming from me i then get
yelled at for telling them anything
and then if they call and have this
conversation it's kind of like i'm a
professional coach
i know what i'm doing um and i think one
thing about
you know this the whole situation as
well is
my dad is a doctor but if you meet any
good
doctor right if something's not their
area of expertise
they're always going to be like no go to
somebody who like isn't ob gyn
is an orthopedist etc etc um
and i think you know there kind of was
this feeling of like
this is nike this is a team that has
like a multi-million dollar budget
is paying people high amounts of money
is
kind of um presenting themselves
as this incredibly professional
organization like
one-of-a-kind situation um and if you
know they're being told that i'm working
with somebody for my mental health and
my nutrition and
all that sort of stuff like they're
gonna assume that's true
right and then it's gonna be somebody
who's really good exactly
but this guy this sports psychologist
darren treasure that was his name um
i read i think this was in chris
chavez's
si piece that anything that any of the
athletes shared with that guy
just ended up back with alberto like
there was
this um uh kind of expectation of
privacy that
in fact was not private at all like it
all funneled back to
um salazar again you know him being a
puppeteer and controlling the flow of
information between everybody
yes and you know i came up in a
household where there was a doctor
and somebody who really prided
themselves on
being a good doctor and being somebody
who never overstepped the rules or
things like um patient client privilege
is incredibly important and so
you know when you almost are exposed to
that at a young age and then you're told
somebody's a sports psychologist
i i know what that means and all the
other athletes know what that mean
and so if they're telling something
personal
um or private they're going to assume
that it's not going to be told to
somebody else
let alone their like competitor teammate
or their coach who maybe they're talking
about
um and over time i i really
i think the thing i regret the most is
that there were moments
where i realized what was happening um
in that you know another athlete would
be discussed with me who i knew he
worked with
and in a way that was incredibly
negative um
but rather than take that moment and
stepping back and saying hey
this is inappropriate he's
hypothetically breaking laws if he's
truly a sports psychologist
what is he doing to me instead in those
moments i was just like i'm glad he's
not talking about me
or my weight or saying something mean
about me yeah i think the thing that
that people don't get or or might miss
in trying to understand
this dynamic is that when you're an
athlete at the highest level and you're
on this elite team
there's a couple things at play one of
which is everybody's trying to covet
favor with the coach like everybody
wants to be the
favorite you hear you know carrot
gouchers spoken about this with alberto
like
and when you're in that cat bird seat
and you are the favorite
it doesn't matter what the coach is
saying about the other athletes because
you're
you're going to protect that and just
because you're all on the same team
there isn't the esprit de corps that you
would suspect because
because everybody's vying for a limited
number of olympic slots like these
these may be your teammates and you're
training with them every day and on some
level some surface level
you're mutually supportive but
ultimately like they're your competitors
also so there's a cutthroat aspect of
this so it's working at cross purposes
with
the kind of unity that you would want
with the people you're showing up to
train with every day
yeah absolutely and i think that's why
you know personally i've never
i've never named other athletes like
even in stories that i've told
um in which i'm referring to another
teammate of mine doing something
negative or being in the room or et
cetera
i don't name them because like
personally although i've never
minus a couple of individuals i've never
gotten really like a
hey i heard you i'm sorry moment
um like i don't need that from them
and even though i think their behavior
was bad and poor
and and um the inability for people to
stand up
after the fact and say like yes that was
wrong
is something that i'm always gonna
wonder like
you know it takes a lot of bravery to do
that it takes a lot of vulnerability to
do that
um but it's my maybe ability to
somewhat sympathize is the reason that i
i don't
i like i almost try to keep the athletes
as out of this as i can
yeah i mean i think and listen we should
point out that in the wake of you
sharing your story with the new york
times like
so many people came out to support you
and all these people that were on your
team
have come out of the woodwork to you
know say nice things about you
and also express their regret at not
having
been kind of more aware or supportive in
the moment
yeah and i think that's why it's like um
both
cam levins and dathan ritzenhein were my
two athletes at the time
um who have like since reached out to me
or and
you know publicly um said they witnessed
or
at least in the case of cam like witness
some of this behavior
um is something that like
i always cry when i talk about that um
because i think again like for so many
years when you think it's your fault
um having at least one person
say they thought yeah that's always the
thing that kills me
um and i think it's just because
i know how um brave it is to say
i messed up i know how brave it is to
say i wish i did something different
um and like there are people i wish
that i saved over the years um
and so to have somebody come out and say
that really means a lot
so i always especially you know when
you know if and when they're still part
of the nike family like it you know
there's a lot at stake like it's
it's risky to do that and so you know
yeah that is something to be
appreciated and it's very cool and in
terms of you
thinking uh perhaps you know
some of these situations eluded your
gaze like you're now in this
incredible situation where you can be
this voice for change and i know you've
taken that
mantle seriously and we're going to get
into that
but when i think about alexi like i see
somebody who
really appreciates and understands
the power of mentorship like she's
always seeking out mentors
and she understands her responsibility
and role
as a mentor and in on some level like
that's part of your friendship
dynamic because she's you know a little
bit further down the path and all of
that
and now you know because of your
relationship with alexi and what you've
gone through
i feel like you really get that as well
and i think you know for me as a very
young athlete
um you know one thing that's always a
little awkward and i'm sure
everybody who's ever been kind of on
that
for lack of a better word female phenom
level um
you kind of expect everybody to like
welcome you with open arms because
you're like i'm 12.
like this is fun everybody's giving me a
friend
um and the truth is like you're often
met with a lot of negativity especially
within
like the competitive space and i get it
like if you're a 30 year old competitor
like you don't really want this 18 year
old beating you
um but i think kind of having
felt like i was alone
for so long in sport um and was able to
find a friendship like alexis
like she was one of the first people who
really
took me under their wing and shared
advice and shared stories
um and who didn't just kind of look at
me as purely a competitor
or purely somebody to use for pacing or
whatever
um and as a result now i'm very
cognizant of like the younger generation
and the people who are coming up and um
you know after a race like they're going
to be the first people i'd beeline over
to so that i can invite them to dinner
or
hang out with or just make them feel
like they were a part of the event in a
way that matters
um and it's sad because even even to
this day i mean
i haven't been i haven't been to too
many races there have been a lot of
injuries over the years
um but the ones that i am it's like you
know go over to somebody i'm like why is
nobody else doing this too
um and i think it's because sport in so
many ways
has been at least on the professional
side
um the number of times i'll listen to an
interview and an athlete will say like
well like
you know sport is selfish and i'm like i
think that's a cop out
i think it's selfish if you want it to
be selfish i think if you
you know want to kind of like not give
back
in some way then you can choose not to
but if you want to have a purpose
kind of during your career and and do
something during it
there's always going to be opportunity
too yeah well i think
people are wired in different ways there
are certain competitors who feel like
that's the only path to greatness is if
they're
completely focused on themselves any
athlete
who's excelled with longevity though
realizes that that's an unsustainable
fuel source
and ultimately leads to early retirement
or burnout and the
the true greats at some point even if
they had that mindset
earlier realize that when you're living
when you broaden the aperture on your
life that actually your performance
gets better i mean shalane talks about
that quite a bit as well like when she's
having kids and all of that and trying
to ju
you think or or carrie walsh jennings
right she's like
you know married with kids and trying to
juggle that and saying
oh it actually helps me it makes me a
better competitor but i think at the
same time
there's a systemic misalignment of
incentives in that the sponsorship
ecosystem is set up to
financially reward you for your
performance right and this is something
you're very active in upending but
it's not just hey there's only a few
slots to make the world championship
team or the olympic team
it's that my bank account is contingent
upon
me beating you and if i get beat by you
i
you know my shoe sponsor may not renew
my contract so
you're living event to event and kind of
in fear
of trying to protect your ability to put
food on the table
and so that's going to create a negative
environment in terms of how the athletes
are you know interacting with each other
absolutely and it's going to create the
win at all cost culture
and um you know honestly predispose
people to cheat
um and it's because like i i get it if
that's
if that's your only financial
opportunity and it's all about
competition
um you know and i think the unfortunate
thing too
is like who gets a contract versus who
doesn't
yes it's all about you know performance
and
but you know if you look the right way
like
maybe we're gonna knock you a couple
extra dollars or you know if we
just like the way you interview like
there's no real
metric even and when you look at the
disparity between different people's
contracts because everything is
nda'ed and so nobody like
you know if you're in there's no
transparency about what they so the
athletes don't know
who's getting what exactly and like you
know some people might
like be open and share with others and
other times
it's very tight-lipped and you know the
problem is like
you'll know one person's making below
minimum wage
to compete at really the highest level
and somebody else is doing
incredibly well there's you know and
even the incredibly well side it's just
there's not a lot of money in track and
field
um and i think you know when
athletes aren't able to really negotiate
for themselves when they're not even
aware of like what's a good
price to be negotiating it leaves just
so much
agency out of the hands of the athletes
i feel like the sponsorship
approach that a lot of these brands have
historically taken
is really based on antiquated metrics
like the idea like oh you have to make
this team and go to the these are the
these are the events you're going to
show up at and if you get first you get
this second third
all of that and that is dictating how
much money you make
really doesn't make sense especially in
a social media world like what is the
purpose of a company sponsoring an
athlete it's to engender goodwill in the
brand
and hopefully encourage people
out in the world to purchase their
products well how do you do that
well winning races is just one way but
in an era
where athletes are shouldering the
responsibility of communicating directly
with
audiences and developing their own trust
with those people it's not um
like where where you stand on the podium
no longer
is really the most important thing it's
like who who
do people like who do people trust that
could be
somebody who's not going making any of
these
meets or these competitions and somebody
who no one's ever heard of that has
no audience and no interest in
communicating with the public in any way
and wins you know i don't know the
steeplechase or something like that in
some european race
is that moving the needle in terms of of
the brand
you know so it just doesn't it needs to
be completely
rethought bottom to top and that's why i
love kind of this relationship that you
have with tracksmith you're just
basically a salaried employee
and they're like we love you go do your
thing and you know spread the love of
running
and yeah go do some races but where
you end up in you know in those races
really is not relevant to
your paycheck yeah no not at all and if
anything
i think they value my performance as an
employee more than an athlete
i think if i was dropping the ball and
you know missing all of my
you know assignments i think we'd have a
real talking to even if i made the
olympic team tomorrow
um and i think that's incredibly
important
because it's a way to value athletes is
more than just
products it's a way for me to develop a
career skill
that long term is transferable into
the open market because as much as i
love running as
much as we all love sport everybody
um has a point where they're gonna have
to move on to their next career and
um the truth is no runner is really
getting set up for life
based on their salary it's not like
we're in a professional sports league
where if you make it to 40 like
you're retiring in a really great
financial spot
right um and as a result there's kind of
this
inability for most people in these
traditional contracts
to develop those career skills in a way
that's as supportive as
a relationship like tracksmith and i
have where
um my training my dreams as an athlete
are
like beyond supported and if one day i'm
not
dialing in until 10 30 because i had a
little bit more of an important workout
in the morning
so as a result i'm going to be sending
some emails at 7 pm
that's totally understood and that's
like encouraged that's accepted
and it's not something that i almost
have to like you know
combine two incompatible worlds
um and i think a lot of other athletes
who've had to kind of dive into the
workforce
while sustaining their careers for that
financial support
um it can be harder if you're just in a
traditional company that maybe doesn't
understand why
you have to travel like x amount of
times to go to meets and
kind of random parts of the country
where you know it's expensive yeah
yeah but if you look at other different
kinds of sports and certain legacy
brands like
in the climbing world in the
mountaineering world you look at
um solomon north face
and athletes like rebecca rush and
hillary nelson
conrad anchor alex honold ricky gates
killian journey like these brands are on
board
with these athletes for their life it's
like
go be awesome yep you know just go out
and do cool stuff and we're here to
support you and people love those brands
as a result like it just seems better
obviously
look you know killian and ricky they do
interesting different types of things in
running it's not track and field where
there's a stopwatch and it's really
about metrics but
i think there's something to be learned
yeah from
those brands who have been doing it for
a very long time and now other sports
are trying to catch up to that i mean
surfing it's the same thing with surfers
and
all the you know kind of surf brands
absolutely and i think one thing a lot
of these sports have in common
is that they're all lifestyle sports um
in that a lot of the kind of like
traditional
professional sports that we think of in
the united states at least like football
basketball
um yes you can continue doing them
post-collegiately
but there's like this almost
understanding
that like you're not going to be in the
nfl or there's kind of this separation
where like
i probably can't play again unless we're
doing like a pickup game or i like
really assemble 20 people it's probably
harder to join a league
like it's a lot of you know it almost
takes a lot of scrappiness and ingenuity
to like make sure you can keep playing
but sports like
surfing rock climbing running there's no
barrier
there's no hey i need to find six guys
to play with and even then we need to
find another six guys to play against
you can just lace up you know 80 pairs
of shoes and go for a run
and i think kind of having that
opportunity to really touch so many more
people
makes the idea of this um the way we're
kind of talking about
these you know umbrella them into these
olympic sports
really should lean more towards that how
are you talking
to that everyday athlete because there's
so many more of them out there
and it's not to say that you have to
talk to them you know and therefore like
dumb down how you're talking about
running or you know almost make it
um something where it's like you're not
almost taking the running side of it
seriously
um but instead you can lift all those
people up with you and say like hey i
think you deserve to know how to recover
like i recover i think you deserve to
know how to train
like i train and we can help you um
like come up with ways to like build
that into your life and your schedule
and just
almost create this like incredibly
supportive
community um that i think in a way like
a lot of the
traditional professional sports kind of
don't have the opportunity to tap into
well it's purely based on inspiration
like you have the lebrons and people
like that that
are just you know gods that we look up
to and if they say buy this product
we're expected to buy it right
the difference that you're speaking to
is
is being um
yes you're inspirational but you didn't
go to the olympics and win five gold
medals right you're
you're a much more accessible human
being and so you're more aspirational
like
people aren't going to be able to run as
fast as mary kane
but i like mary kane and she's cool and
she's gonna come out and run with us and
she's gonna help us
along the way like there's a
relationship
aspect of it it's not just somebody on
the billboard that
if you saw them in person you would
freak out exactly and i think the truth
is like even the athletes who win
five olympic gold medals can still
almost do that
in running compared to other sports and
it's because at the end of the day like
running is something that you don't need
that much like extra stuff to do
right like if you have a road if you
have a trail if you have a track
and you know some people don't even wear
a pair of shoes
yeah you can go out and run and the sort
of training i'm doing
versus somebody else yeah you might not
run as much you know maybe
the times are going to be different but
you could still go out there and do an
interval workout
you could still go out there and run a
long run um
and just build it to what works for you
but whether you're
the olympic champion you know 20 times
or
this is your first time running like you
really have something in common
and there's this ability to i believe
connect
in a way that's just really not um or
really overlooked right now
in an unfortunate way yeah well you're
also running around new york city just
like everybody else yeah right running
is one of the few sports where
track and field is different but road
running trail running
the elites are running you know the same
course at essentially the same time
as everybody else so it gives it a
different
vibe entirely and i think
tracksmith is this great you know kind
of platform for you to do that but i
want to talk about
adelanta atlanta how do you say it i
want to know where this word came from
but
because you're really inverting the
whole
business model with what you're doing
with this this new team
yeah so i think just to start off i'll
maybe explain the name
um which is in sixth grade being the
nerd that i am
um i took latin and at the very
beginning of the
year we had to pick a you know
mythological
name and that would be the name we'd be
called like throughout the year
um and at the time i was not a runner i
had
run a 547 mile as a sixth grader just as
like an
after school right gym you're not i'm
not a runner i just i just ran
547 in sixth grade yes so i like
acknowledge that
in so much just to say i take back all
the stuff about you being relatable like
go ahead
when i went to my dad who had taken you
know kind of years of latin himself and
i was like oh
what should be what should be the name i
take he immediately was like
that 547 let's do atlanta and the reason
is it's this like really beautiful greek
myth
um about a woman who is a human being
they're not a goddess um but they're the
fastest
being in the world and they're faster
than all
men they're faster than all the gods and
the goddesses um
and so much of their myth is this like
more feminist based me i mean like as
much as
like alyssa strata kind of thing yes
where it's like
you know she is a warrior and an
athlete like from the wonder woman
island exactly
exactly what about achilles they just
kicked him to the curb yeah no she's
she's faster she's faster um and so
i like always loved that for seven years
when i took latin like that was my latin
name
um and it was just one of those stories
that always you know was kind of
in the back of my head um and then
recently
when i was going on this endeavor to
start a program
i mentioned like oh we're coming up with
names and i threw that out there
to one of my co-workers at york road
runners and it turns out
the first ever women's high performance
team
in the u.s was based in new york city in
the 1970s
and that was their name wow and i
immediately was like
there's never really been a professional
team in new york but that is the closest
thing that's come to it and i'm like
let's bring it back
wow i just got like goosebumps that's
very cool thank you
and so this is set up this is the other
interesting thing here
you you've set this up as a non-profit
so it's a non-profit but then
and it's got kind of two prongs as i
understand it there's going to be this
elite
running team of like six to eight
athletes um
and then there's a whole community arm
that entails
outreach and getting kids on the track
and all of that
but the professional athletes that are
going to comprise this team
are going to be paid employees of the
non-profit
like that's never been done before
that's super interesting
yeah so one thing you know that i'll
immediately call out
is that certain teams across the country
in olympic movement
sports are like registered as
non-profits
and the reason is is like the amateur
athlete act
of some year made it so that that was an
opportunity but we're not a non-profit
in name only we're
like a non-profit and that we're
actually going to be doing service work
in the community
um and in many ways like i had just
always seen this problem of the elite
end of sport and wanted to solve it
and my relationship with tracksmith was
one in which i realized
giving athletes like a full-time
employment opportunity where they're
building career skills
taking on an actual job um while still
being fully supported to train
is an incredible model and one in which
i
was always trying to figure out like how
can i grow this
how can i give more people this
opportunity um
but i think the thing that kept kind of
you know sticking in the back of my head
is
it will be great to help the
professional side of sport but how can i
make this bigger
like how can i help people who maybe
never aspire to go on the professional
end
and to me that was giving back to
younger athletes in the local community
um who just maybe have been left behind
in terms of programming to like get them
into sport and stay in sport and
um not only do it for this performance
end but like
learn all the skills around healthy
sport and keeping a positive mindset and
a lot of the things that maybe as a
young girl had i learned
um would have helped me like maintain a
more positive relationship
with sport forever um when instead
i kind of ended up falling through this
period of time where i almost left it
yeah putting that fordham business
degree to work
yeah coming in handy right now right my
pre-med has been very much left behind
and i like how you know you sent me the
deck for this venture and as i'm
scrolling through it i liked how
robust the part was about the community
outreach
and working with kids and the mentor
like it wasn't because
there's almost like a green washing
thing with this stuff where it's like oh
yeah we're doing that but it's not
really about that because it's going to
be about these eight
team members and how we're gonna crush
it but the feeling that i got was that
that's actually the very real part of it
and even the
um mindfulness that went into the
intention that went into like
we're not gonna go to the parks where
this stuff already exists like we're
gonna identify the parks where this
doesn't exist and we're going to
establish that and it's going to be an
after school thing and a saturday
morning thing and there's going to be
always two mentors and two athletes from
the team like you've thought this
through yeah this has been a few months
coming
at this point we technically
incorporated in december
of 2020 um and i probably started
working
on it sometime in november and the
reason it's
taken this amount of time to like fully
launch and get off the ground um
is because i want to do it right and i
want to do it um
in a way where it's it's not like i'm
you know leaning
too heavily on one side versus the other
um
but instead like i want this to be a
non-profit that like outlasts my running
career
um i want there to be a certain point
where you know
we've gone through three four iterations
of athletes
who have all been able to move on to
their next step post career and and i
am a part of that journey and the only
way you can have that is if you set a
really strong foundation
um and in particular on the service side
where i
like totally honestly have less
expertise and therefore had to lean on
more people and work with
others and set up like an advisory board
in which
i was getting that level of support to
really make that
service dream a reality is
has been really really incredible and
something that like i just
i can't wait for the first program yeah
do you know who the
elite athletes are going to be the team
already
i can't name people yet because we're
answers yes but you're not going to tell
me exactly
like we're primarily recruiting ncaa
athletes
um and so that's as much as i'll say
um but i think the big thing is like who
we're recruiting in this like maybe more
abstract way
um are women who are excited by this who
are
buying into the system who say yes
like the ability to one just give back
and develop mentorship skills um go
through
the appropriate training to be able to
um
like perform this service work is
something that
i think a lot of women who you know i'm
technically like the end of the line for
millennials based on textbooks
and so most of these girls borderline
exactly so most of these girls are the
generation
below me um and i think this like
idea of giving back is something that
really really resonates with them
um and the ability to actually develop
career skills and take on like
a true job while
at the same time having their
professional running career fully
supported
is something that i think people are
excited about
because when you think of great athletes
you know you think of the megan rapinos
of the world and the thing is
megan is an incredibly talented soccer
player like we love watching her on the
field
but like megan means more to the world
than her soccer performance
and i think you know as younger athletes
kind of look up at that
you know generation of greatness they
realize that like
the people who they really um are
inspired by
are those who are we're advocates in
some way we're giving back in some way
um you know greatness happens off the
field as much as it does on
um and i think that that kind of
recognition
is something that makes them think hey
like this can be my start
yeah i think that's right and i think
that's
powerful young people whether it's
athletes or just
activists in general people who have a
cause that they care about and they make
their lives um
meaningful uh in that regard is
become that's become like an
aspirational thing for young people
which makes me optimistic about the
future you know what i mean
it's not enough to just go kill it and
win a race
who are you and what are you about and
how are you using that responsibility
and whatever platform you've established
as a result of that to actually
you know create the world you know
create a better world exactly and i mean
i would say the same thing where it
gives me a lot of hope
because of course whenever you're
starting something new and never done
before and completely unique
there's that fear of you know for all of
the people who i've had
buy in because they've joined my board
or donated or coming on as sponsors
um will i then turn towards the athletes
and be kind of
told no again and again and again um
and i think to just like feel the
excitement
in those were um you know going to be
bringing on and
like knowing that there's this um
understanding of being a part of
something bigger and and also
like being a part of change and like
this is something where i don't
i don't want us to be like the first
and the only um i want this to become a
model that's
that's taken seriously um heck if other
organizations want to step up and do the
same thing
like to me that's incredible and that
that shows that i'm doing something
um that like can really push the sport
forward but
if it just ends up having to be me
starting this in different cities across
the world like
that that's that's another thing too
that i'll try yeah yeah
no it's super cool i mean i think you
know in the wake of you
coming out and sharing your story uh if
you had just
found a way to fall back in love with
running and and maybe
you know performed well most people
would be like that's cool
but you've really taken this on like
shoulder this responsibility
to be an example of the change that
you're speaking about like you're not
just
talking about it you actually are doing
something yeah and i think that's always
been something that's been really
important to me in this process and
i feel for a while i've been um just
like dying to tell people about this
because i'm like i'm really doing
something um
but i think it's just kind of like that
that cliche of i didn't want to just
talk the talk i wanted to walk the walk
um and i try to do that in my day-to-day
anyway like the way i
talk to myself and treat myself like i i
try to
um exude like this you know idea of
healthy sport
as best as i can and you know i try to
give back
um to our local running community but i
just
always felt like there was something
bigger that i could be doing
um and i think part of it is that new
york city has never had a professional
team
um and to be actually bringing one to
this community that in so many ways like
kept me in the sport feels like the
ultimate
thank you because it's a way for us to
not just
uplift the girls that we're servicing in
in the local community but
also the broader running community of
new york and um
hopefully help create something that
gets even more excitement
drives even more people to central park
to run with
um and just yeah i think it's going to
be something where
there's there's a lot to learn and a lot
to do but i'm excited for that
how are you bankrolling this whole thing
is is tracksmith a partner or where does
the
funding come from yep they'll be an
apparel sponsor
of the program but how we're also
differentiating ourselves is it's not
just a one
um apparel sponsor footing the bill um
instead we're kind of taking this like
multi-revenue approach to the program
so we have sponsorships such as
tracksmith
um and then donations um are another
opportunity for us to be able to grow
because um
we are again a service-based nonprofit
and then lastly we are going to unveil a
membership
side to this um where you know if you
want to get
training programs if you want to get
behind the scenes kind of
access to the athletes we're trying to
be
much more open as an organization and
and not just use the mentorship skills
that we develop to give back
sure to the younger athletes um but to
also have like
actual programming that you know if
you're a member
of the organization like we're hosting
weekly bi-weekly
events and there's conversations with
experts and there's
um almost a lot of the programming that
we will be doing
like in the parks and
like also being given to our members
it's great
so when's this whole thing kick off um
june
so it's happening very soon yeah that's
cool
we'll be back in a sec but first if you
dig this podcast and i hope you dig this
podcast then i think you'll really enjoy
my latest
book voicing change featuring excerpts
from
poignant essays by and glorious
photography
of some 50 of my favorite guests over
the last
eight plus years of doing this thing
this podcast
it's a gorgeous artful compendium of the
show
and copious wisdom shared therein all
wrapped in
a hardcover coffee table form that
provides a great taste of what we do
here
at the rrp and serves as a beautiful
keepsake or gift for the ardent fan
the book is only and exclusively
available on our website
signed copies are available and we are
shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet
earth so to learn more and snag your
copy today
visit richroll.com vc
that's richroll.com vc
all right let's get back into it
we got to get back to the uh we we kind
of like
diverted from the timeline it's all good
no it was good i wanted to hear all
about that
um back to uh
the nike oregon project and when you
were running so
you're starting to have um
disordered eating issues you end up
uh uh not being able to
have your period for like three years or
something like that and then you end up
having like
five stress fractures and that's the
result of
when you're not menstruating you're
starting to have all kinds of bone
density issues
right yeah i i had bone loss and my
numbers
um had started to get to like a
concerningly low level and
um it took a lot of intervention to
like re-strengthen them as much as i
could because between the years of like
18 to 22 were your peak bone growth and
i
didn't have my period between the ages
of 18 and 21 and a half
yeah it's so pretty bad yeah
it just it reminds me i spoke about this
um with lauren fleshman who i know you
know
um and it really speaks to
again this like systemic issue of of
this kind of male-dominated paradigm
where the men who are
the support system and the coaches are
training women
fundamentally like men and
built into that is this assumption that
that women's bodies
uh adapt and change in the same way that
dudes do and it's just not the case like
the way that the female body you know
sort of matures over time
is extremely different you were talking
about yeah when you're a girl and you're
you're starting to put on a little bit
of weight like that's normal
um but that hammer to just like always
keep your weight down always keep your
weight down
you know leading people into this um
situation of disordered eating i mean
it's really
a big problem it's yeah and i think you
know a big thing i always like to
start off saying is that whenever i say
women's training needs to be different
than men
like we can train as hard as guys like
if anything i i think the women can
train harder
some of the workouts i've seen people do
like we can grind um
but there are certain things that are
different and need to be accounted for
like even just the fact that over the
course of a four week period of time
like
there are so many studies about like if
you're in your pms week
bluntly you're probably not going to be
performing quite as well
and that doesn't mean you shouldn't push
through and sometimes you know
kind of continue to like grind
um but there should be this
acknowledgement that okay maybe the
sort of times we're targeting this week
can be a little adjusted or
if you're in a program that like builds
for three weeks and drops for a week
maybe if we try to align that with that
week that would be more beneficial
so like super kind of science-y
sciency-oriented
opportunities or something that very
very few people talk about
um but the other thing is that for women
how we're built physically and how we
develop
you know guys it's just like an upward
trajectory perpetually
it's like yeah it's pretty
straightforward girls there's there's
always that
kind of college year slump and that's
you know that's okay
like that's just a thing and maybe one
girl doesn't experience
that maybe one girl hits it really
really hard um
but if you're like lifted through that
and you're supported through that
then you're gonna get to 22 and then
you're gonna have that kind of like
resurgence of um you know
kind of like knowing your body and your
body kind of being in this
space where like it's done yeah well
there's a later peak to it
right and understanding that there's
going to be peaks and valleys through
those interim years and not making a big
to-do about
that or having it be a referendum on how
the rest of your career is going to play
out i think is really important and i
think
that change only happens when you are
staffing
these teams with women coaches and women
psycho you know it's like you got to
have people
who understand this yes who can help
these young women
through this process and not hold them
to expectations that are ultimately not
in their long-term best interests
as an athlete exactly because i think
one thing too is that
you know all of the issues that i've
spoken about
like reds relative energy deficiency and
sport
um which is essentially when you're
under fueling
and or over training and or therefore
developing
um you know different physical reactions
such as bone loss
um men can experience that as well
but the bar at which you start to break
down
is like easier for women to hit and it's
because physically we're supposed to
carry a little bit more fat
where you know we have this almost um
like like our fail-safe of like
reproductive health is gonna drop before
a man's does um and as a result we
almost
like it's not that we can't push
ourselves as hard
but going over the red line um too
often is more risky and there's more
opportunities for things to start to
break down just
because biologically we're different um
and i think
that's why like having people
who understand and can relate
and sympathize and have their own
experiences such as other female coaches
or
support staff is always going to be
helpful um
but it's also incredibly important so
that the men who are
also in those positions and also want to
be coaching or support staff
do the work and put in the time and
educate themselves and
um i think that's can be said about so
many different things like
just as we need more women in sport
we need more diverse individuals getting
these positions
and i always say that any culture
that supports inclusivity and supports
diversity
and supports this ability to have
different opinions in a room and
different experiences in a room and
backgrounds
is always going to be a better culture
than one
in which it's just one type of person
so for as much as we need more women we
we also need more people of
all sorts of backgrounds being able to
be in those positions because
that just ability to find ways to relate
um with one another and it's just super
powerful
yeah there's always going to be the cult
of personality with
you know certain coaches though it kind
of feels like
that's the way it is maybe that can
change i don't know yeah
i think when we're talking about this
we're talking about biology and
physiology but there's also the
psychology of all of it right
absolutely um you know on the one hand
we should point out
that weight is factor in performance
in running and in lots of sports um so
it's not about
hey we can't talk about that or that's a
verbatim subject
um but maybe don't you know make your
athletes
weigh themselves in front of the other
athletes like you know there's
there's a way of doing this right so how
do you have
a productive if you're a coach or you're
an athlete
how do you talk about this in a
meaningful productive way
well i think the first thing is that you
have to
do get yourself educated um and whether
it's things like safe sport training
or working with a nutritionist yourself
or having
um and also i'm gonna actually backtrack
registered dietitian especially if
you're with younger athletes i
really recommend um working with
somebody who's done
the full training that's required to
like have
a dietitian's degree um i think
nutritionism is like kind of this
buzzword
um but the truth is like the more you're
working with true
experts and people who have devoted
their life to understanding this
um the better equipped you're going to
be because
you know most coaches aren't registered
dietitians and
most coaches maybe have not had that
level of
you know education on this topic so the
more you're leaning on people who have
is super important um and i think
another thing is as a coach
you know you also have to like work with
somebody like a therapist or
um you know a psychologist to also
make sure you're not bringing any of
your
kind of own perspectives onto the track
and i think that's really important
because
you know a lot of these issues we're
talking about
are being talked about really loudly
right now but if you were maybe an
athlete in the 90s and
you yourself kind of went through these
experiences
even if you know they were wrong i think
so
often people kind of bring their own
history and their own
maybe discomfort with food into things
so i think that kind of first step is
like take care of yourself get get the
education that you can work with the
professionals that you can
and see if you can also kind of find out
where your own biases lie
um that's number one and then number two
is really encourage your athletes to
similarly
work with those people and once you've
maybe like assembled that team or have
like
a list of resources try to find ways to
build that into your programming
and and really make sure that the
language
around food and the language around
weight and body inclusivity is always as
positive as you can
um and if you're not
the professional do not pretend to be
that
so if you are concerned about an
athlete's
you know weight being too heavy for
example
um like if you like that's not really
your
place to um
give them a weight that they need to hit
because there is no ideal weight like
you don't know you're like the
registered dietitian would look at you
like that's not a thing
like you can't give somebody an
arbitrary number um and so i think the
more you kind of
like try to stay in your lane try to
direct people
to the resources that like truly are
going to help them
um while at the same time educating
yourself as much as possible right
important
and if you're a coach maybe maybe don't
like bully or athletes and
talk about the other athletes in
front of the other athletes and create
some crazy culture of fear so that mary
kane has to go
you know steal cliff bars and and you
know nibble on them in the dark
right yeah so look this whole thing
plays i mean
basically in pretty short shrift after
you end up
in oregon it's not working out right how
long were you there before you're like
i'm out of here and i'm like done with
all this
yeah so well so i think the big thing to
say is that i
left portland um by the end of my
freshman year
so i was out there for about a year um
but
and this is this is where i always like
kick myself looking back
that wasn't some big oh this was bad i'm
leaving moment
this was more me apologizing to
everybody
because you couldn't live up to
alberto's standards yes you couldn't cut
it
exactly so i moved home to new york and
i told everybody like
i have disordered eating like i have
been trying to make myself throw up
and i can't do this like this is super
unhealthy
um i'm cutting myself like my mental
health is fully deteriorating
i'm really sorry but i just need like to
figure this out
and then i'll come back so that was the
plan just to back up for a second
when you because you told did you tell
alberto or one of the coaches that you
were cutting yourself
right yeah and what was the response it
was
after um this race
that had been delayed and so it was late
at night and i was
like truthfully having like a full like
breakdown
and i was really scared that i was gonna
hurt myself
and so i went to alberto and the sports
hikes room and i told them like i'm
i just tried to make myself throw up
multiple times in the bathroom
like i've been cutting myself at this
point the sports that had already caught
me doing it a couple times so he knew
that i was um
and i was like i like i don't know what
to do like i really need help
um and this is the other thing that
always makes me cry
um i was told that they wanted to go to
sleep
because it was late and
that like crushed me in a way that i
like i don't know what i thought they
were gonna do
but i think i just thought they would do
something um
and so the next day i called my mom who
i at that point i hadn't been
talking to like honestly and openly
um and i told her i
have like a really bad relationship with
food now
and um i didn't tell her that i was
cutting myself at the time i was like
too embarrassed
um and so my mom had and dad at that
point had been like
not spoken to by the coaches for a while
there had been too many moments of like
red flags and me saying something and
then getting in trouble and
them kind of being scared across the
country um
and so they like booked a flight home
the next day i got
on a plane to new york um and the plan
was like i'm going to
like get myself back together so that
i'm tough enough to like rejoin the team
fully so i spent a year in new york
that was always the plan to go back and
let's just like for me
pause for a moment i mean i'm so sorry
that that happened to you
and it's it's infuriating that you would
go
to was it the was it this the
psychologist person and like literally
say like this is what i'm doing and i
need help
and that person says i'm tired i need to
go to bed i mean it's just
it's unbelievable yeah and i mean he had
caught me doing it a couple times and
you know both times it was just kind of
like knock it off um
and like waved off and that's helpful he
he'd seen me like
self-harm myself in other ways as well
like there was a track workout in which
a lot of people witness this
unfortunately
um but i started hitting myself
and um i like
so sad but i was supposed to run 400.
and if you've ever been to nike's track
there's trees in the middle
so i ran a 200 and i ran off the track
and i ran towards where like the bridle
is
and i don't know what was in my head i
think i just wanted to like
get off campus and like run into traffic
honestly
um and like the sports like ran after me
i was hitting myself and they dragged me
back onto the track and i had to finish
the workout
and um you know in those moments
i think what people don't always
recognize is that like
to me even saying this now like i'm so
embarrassed that i did that
like to me like even though i know
everything that had happened like that
feels very unprofessional
so when i'm being told at 18
that you're being super unprofessional
knock it off get on the track finish it
you're you're like already in a really
bad place so you're not
thinking hey why aren't you helping me
this is clearly a sign of distress
instead i'm thinking
yeah i agree with you like this is super
unprofessional i'm really sorry
i'm sorry i'm you know disrupting the
workout like is everybody else okay
okay like i'm gonna cry myself around
the track now for the next four laps
um and i say that not
to you know
really do anything more than for anybody
right now who's had that
like sort of experience where they
relate to the fact that
you know something wasn't done for them
but
rather than kind of recognize it as
wrong
in that moment and maybe even right now
they were still saying sorry don't say
sorry
in those moments the right thing to do
would have been get me help
in those moments the right thing that
anybody should have done
would shut that down and like intervene
right and if anybody should have had the
wherewithal
to do that it's the nike oregon project
the most well-funded
elite track and field situation you know
perhaps in the world it would be one
thing
if it was some high school track coach
that didn't know any better and it's
like all right well
you know maybe that guy just you know
he's not trained to
know what to do in that situation but
it's really inexcusable
that that went down the way that it did
yeah and i mean like to this day like i
have no idea if any of those individuals
are safe sports certified
and if they are like they're i mean i
am and there are multiple modules where
you can't watch that and not be like
well we've broken 40 of these rules
at a different time yeah well i think
there's a lot of education that needs to
be done around that and
yes and also the the um
the scope of what safe sport is about
because i think there's this sense
that it's about um sexual abuse or
doping
only and that's kind of the limits you
know i think
people need to better understand that it
does expand to
all of these kind of mental health
situations and it's not at all about
doping
um it's all about really like a coach's
guidebook to abuse
and and what not to do and i think the
really
like incredible thing about their
programming is the fact that
it's real i mean it's really well done
and it's done by professionals and i
recommend
every single individual that works with
any sort of athlete whether you're a
parent
whether you're an athlete yourself a
coach like an ad
get yourself safe sport certified even
if it's not required of you
and the reason is there's so many
different things that i even look back
on my experience and i'm like
god that that was part of the toxicity
like if you're working with like a 16 or
17 year old
you know like they probably shouldn't
stay in your house
when they're traveling yeah you know
like you probably shouldn't be texting
each other
like every day and you know
all of those sort of barriers that
create this sense of almost like
connection
or you know like this like family bond
if you will
um are really like
not positive things because like
it this is a child and you shouldn't be
overstepping like that
and so when things start to go wrong
that kid's first
thought is going to be like this person
is like
my uncle sure yeah i can't let them down
yeah yeah well it's more than that this
is the person who's going to help me
realize my dream
and this is the person who believes in
me and who is telling me that i'm
capable of these things it's
unbelievably intoxicating
yes but what the point that i'm trying
to make is
i understand well how potent and
powerful that dynamic is and when you're
a young person and you're that
impressionable
you don't want your parent your parents
like what they have to say is irrelevant
like you're protecting this very you
feel
very special you are the person who is
touched
and you are going places and everybody
else get out of the way and i'm going to
listen to what this coach says
and you have no ability
to um gauge
the unhealthy nature of it because you
don't know any different
no and you're looking at your teammates
and whenever you ask them for help
they're saying like buy in stop
complaining do what you're told he's the
best
coach he's gonna get you to the top and
you know i think
like an elephant in the room that maybe
needs to be addressed with all of this
is that like you know like
my old coach alberto isn't just banned
by safe sport
he's also banned by usada and so
in retrospect there's always that part
of me that's like
you know i kept saying no to thyroid
medication
i kept saying no to using an inhaler i
didn't use
birth control for weight loss reasons
because i knew
at that point like there were deeper
problems going on
the birth control was his his means of
addressing
the period thing right no no so that
i misread that man so he has since
said that but the reason i was put
or i didn't actually take it so i wasn't
like i was given
physician samples birth control um
from his his own doctor who
was friends with him is because he felt
that i was
bloating a lot and he felt some of my
weight
might be because this is just gonna all
sound crazy
because i was really still cycling and
maybe still pmsing but just not bleeding
sorry for i should have got given like a
content warning for that
um and as a result he thought some of my
weight was because i was super bloated
and we needed to bloat me and so that's
why it
you know diuretics had been thrown out
diuretics are not allowed i said no
um and then birth control became this
thing that he decided
would really help me lose weight which
doesn't make any sense
and isn't a thing but i was brought into
the doctor
um she gave me
birth control because he wanted me to
lose weight
and you know what the the thing is like
you know
if i went in there and i said hi like
i'm an 18 year old girl i want birth
control for birth control purposes
they can give you like they can kind of
just give them to you
right but if i go in like samples yes
but if i go into the doctor's office
with my coach
who i'm not related to and they sit
through the whole appointment
and talk about how i need to lose weight
like
we think birth control is going to help
and they give them to you yeah that's
crazy
that's insane that's crazy what what
what other
kind of doping stuff did you see or that
was
impressed upon you you know i think the
thing is and i
i always come back to this is like i was
just the person who always said no
and it wasn't from anything other than
the fact that like
again i think i took so much of this
like
you know oh no like they probably don't
even know diuretics aren't allowed like
let me explain to them that i'm not
going to take them because like make
sure you never encourage somebody else
to do it kind of way
the 17 18 year old is gonna explain it
exactly and um you know
i think a big thing was that like really
early on
i was always like everything had to be
triple checked with
the global dro which is you know how you
know something's banned so i would eat
thumbs and be like panicly like trying
to figure out toms were banned right
so like that was a big thing when i was
like in high school
and then as soon as i went out there it
kind of became more like no you're good
and it was kind of more like you know
hey i know your dad had said thyroid
you know might be bad before but like
your numbers are kind of on the lower
end they're not low but like maybe we
should
like do this um and i'd be like no
like you know my dad has said you're not
supposed to take that if you don't need
it
um or it would be like hey you're always
breathing really heavy while running
um you know maybe you have asthma like
maybe you need an inhaler right
always trying to find the medical
exemption yeah and i was given an
inhaler at some point i never took it
because i remember
again being so like guys like i think
you're making a mistake
um and again are you getting the
periodic knock on the door and doing
that
the getting drug tested yeah i was drug
tested a ton
um and i i always joke like i was in
that big like fancy bears leak
um i my information was like threatened
to be leaked
but on it it said like two flintstone
vitamins and like
two iron tablets and like vitamin d and
so they've never released it
and i felt so like both like vindicated
but also kind of like
put out that i'm on flintstone vitamins
like watch them cower
as i walk onto the track um but the
thing is like i
i was always saying no and it was always
coming back to weight
of like well you need this because like
thyroid can make you skinnier too
and birth control for you know weight
loss and
um i think that's just important to like
say um because
sometimes it also just makes me be like
when the other athletes were like
just buy in already yeah like
was that something else and the answer
is
i don't know and um
sometimes i wish i could go back and
have been like
more conscious in those moments of like
what was really going on but was there
pressure from
the other athletes to like get on board
with some kind of protocol
um well we did have like a team bonding
trip and during it
one of the athletes did tell me that
like i needed to step up and
stop being such a baby and um you know
like kind of you either gotta buy in or
you're not on the team
sort of talk um and like
it was funny because it was this like
team bond like team bonding
trip and i was the first person to talk
and i was like this was so much fun like
we made memories and friendship
and i'm 12. and then the next person to
go was like
you know you you have to step it up like
you know you can't
like you either have to be professional
or like off this team kind of talk and i
was like well
the friendships are over
so um i think you know i think it's just
like i'm i'm only saying this because i
think
you know in so many ways
the reason that this system of current
sponsorship
is troubling is because
all lines become blurred right because
if everything is about performance
right well things like weight is going
to be overstepped
but how much of the weight overstepping
was because there was maybe a want for
like cheating to happen i don't i don't
know
um and so like when everything is about
performance
then kind of like however you get there
people act like it's okay and if it
means burning some people out if it
means stepping all over people
if it means you know treating people
poorly
you know it's it's not personal it's
business was always the catchphrase that
i used to hear
and i'm like you know businesses that
operate like this
um aren't good yeah
and usually ultimately that comes to
light and and there has to be a
reckoning and
you know i think society should never
condone that sort of behavior
um for the sake of performance because
there are plenty of people who are
performing
incredibly and who don't do that
well this did all come out i mean all of
this was going on for you in like 2015
right yeah so 2015 2016 i was still on
the team
um what ultimately happened was that
again i had
like kind of wanted to i stayed on the
team and i wanted to ultimately like be
back on the team in this full way
but as i had mentioned earlier i had
never told my parents about the cutting
they only knew that i was struggling
with food and
after the olympic trials my current
coach
john henwood um caught me
cutting myself and
he immediately called my parents and was
like
i'm really sorry like she asked me not
to call you
but i'm really scared for her and
i don't know what to do i don't know
what i'm supposed to do in this
situation
um but i'm here with her like you know
i like i need help hmm
he did what you're supposed to do he did
what a grown-up would do
and he admitted and he admitted that he
didn't know he
he admitted that he didn't know how to
handle it um
and i was so mad at him for like years
afterwards
and i liked it i always loved john like
it wasn't like that but
you know to me it was like this like
horrible moment because one i was super
embarrassed
and not my parents know and that's
embarrassing and two
um like my parents were like you you
have to leave this team
like this is destroying you this is like
this is tearing you apart you have to
leave
and i think for there was like a period
of time where my parents could not
understand
why i like so
couldn't see like you know that that the
system was a problem and i think part of
it was like they didn't know a lot of
these stories
these stories that i'm telling now um i
sat my parents down
before the new york times piece came out
and i just told them everything and so
there's so many moments that like i've
never talked about
and like aren't even public um
that like they almost saw what was
happening to me
but they didn't even know how it was
happening um
but you know they told me like this is a
bad
setup for like you you have to like have
health be in your number
one and so i left the team and then
the sad you know irony is that
like that's when my body was finally
like you've been doing damage for so
many years like
my bone density was lowered
substantially and
then i started to break um and it was
this kind of
like tragic like
yes i had left but i think because i
didn't
actually let go and i didn't actually
understand
like what was wrong with the situation
that it just
like i was in this cycle um
and the truth is what snapped me out of
it was when the usada report came out
um in which alberta was banned i
my first like my immediate reaction was
like
no way like he didn't do anything that
was literally that was
literally my first reaction to it and i
the next day read the whole entire
report
it's like 270 pages i read it word for
word
and holy crap
it was the first time i saw on paper
that they lied
and there's so many moments in it where
it'll say something like
you know athletes on the team were told
that you know um usada had given them
permission
to do blank right and like i'd been told
that i thought that was true like of
course
yes this giant company that's telling me
that like
we got full approvals don't worry about
it all these allegations are lies
you're kind of like like i don't know
they're worth billions of dollars i
think they're telling the truth um
what's your sense of how high up that
went
at nike very
you know and i like the ceo stepped down
that high i mean he was on the emails
yeah and again some of this stuff
happened before i was on the team
actually
like right well then yeah all these
people have come out going
back to 2008 right telling stories about
this
yeah and and so i like i was always
there was no like i almost was never
there firsthand
i was only ever hearing things
secondhand um because i joined the team
in 20 well i started working with
alberto in 2012 officially joined the
team in 2013
and it was around then that allegation
started to pop up
right so i'm already in the bubble i'm
already in the system and when you're
being told like
no that was misconstrued like you know
all
ten of us are saying this was actually
what happened you weren't there
but like you know here's some story
you're kind of like i trust these people
they're my friends like
you know they wouldn't do me wrong um
and so i as i was reading the usada
report
there were all of these moments of me
being like oh my god usada is telling me
that i was lying to
and i'm one of the athletes that they're
sub tweeting in this thing of saying
they thought this was the thing and i
like
was just like frozen
and like even now trying to describe the
feeling it's like i
had just so many emotions run through me
because like that was when the flood
like opened
for me internally and i suddenly was
like
whoa if everything in this was a lie
then like what else was happening that
i've
never let myself come to terms with and
the thing is have you
talked to me the day before the usada
report came out
and you looked me in the eye and you
said i know everything you went through
you were
emotionally abused i would have laughed
at your face so i would have walked away
and like
what is that guy talking about um
but as soon as i knew
like i could look back
on my experience and i could see the
lies
and i could see the abuse for what it
was
um that was the most
both empowering and like terrifying
right it shatters the illusion
complete shattering and you know again
like
i think really the scary thing about
abuse
is that the reason it takes years for
people to come out
is because so often they don't even know
that's what it was and for me
it was like as soon as i knew
that was what had happened like my first
thought was
holy crap there's other people who don't
know and
that also explains why you wanted back
on the team right which is
part and parcel of nike's big defense
and all of this like what do you mean
she's saying all this stuff she was
trying to get back on the team i'm like
yeah
we didn't know anything about it so
right so this
is so well salazar gets banned in
september of 2019 right so
does that report come out in advance of
that or do those things
they came out at the same time and then
like six weeks later the new york times
piece came out right and it was the
longest six weeks of my life
so there's a good like three year period
where you go from being mary kane
fastest girl in america bright future
you know olympic glory is a foregone
conclusion for this person there was
even a new york times article about you
like in 2015 right
which was a whole glorious picture
you're like whitewashing this whole
experience but then there's
this period where you disappear right
it's like what happened to mary kane
like she just vanished off the landscape
you go home
you're trying to piece yourself back
together during this period of time it's
like this fallow era where
suddenly you're nowhere to be found
then so you're dealing with what you're
dealing with and trying to
come to terms with this but still buying
into all of it thinking you're going to
make your way back right until this
report comes out
and like i'll say this right so i you
know
was like i'm not tough enough like i
can't handle it like i
i'm maybe not like built to be a pro
right
and what ended up happening was i kind
of had this like
um like injury
and again my parents like my coach john
nobody like i hadn't really shared a lot
of these stories with
um there was maybe like inklings of it
and pieces of it
but like like with everything you're
just
like if i can't even look back on that
like how could i share that with
somebody else
and so um you know around
like probably like in the beginning of
that year it was like
maybe 2018 summer um alberto and i had
talked like once
and it was kind of meant for me to be my
like closure moment
of being like okay and are you still
you're still getting paid by nike though
throughout this period
um yeah i was still i yeah i
my contract ended december 31 2018. so i
was still a nike athlete so it wasn't
like
weird in a way that there was like that
kind of moment
and then kind of between then and when i
was maybe hurt at the beginning of 2019
um like he kind of kept like reaching
out to my coach just see like how am i
doing
like you know like friendly stuff i
think okay we're
we're fine right and then you know
i was i got hurt we asked like oh any
tips
i ended up going out to portland and for
me
a lot of it was like i again i still had
this like
you know i felt so bad about everything
that had happened
and i talked very openly
with alberto about the fact that like
you know i developed like a really
serious eating
you know um disordered eating and i i
used the word disordered eating instead
of eating disorder
because i wasn't bulimic and i wasn't
anorexic
um you know in terms of the like true
clinically diagnosed
definition um but i under it
substantially and i was underweight
a lot and i went through like big
fluctuations and i would try to purge
and i wouldn't be successful um so
it's kind of more within that like yeah
disordered eating bucket
um but i you know i shared this
and it was kind of like okay
like of just not like acknowledged and i
think that was kind of like a little bit
like uh
like wow like i guess like
i guess that's
like to me i think at the time it was
almost this like
yeah yeah we like yeah you weren't you
couldn't handle it
you know and i think that so in his in
other words
in other words sorry to interrupt you in
other words in his mind
you being a product and not a person
he'd already made the decision
that you were damaged goods yeah and
it's like oh that's fine you can come
and tell me that but like i already knew
this wasn't going to work out and i've
moved on
totally and so you're kind of like okay
like cool
but like you know i'm still like trying
to try and be a pro whatever
but i'm at that point like pretty like
okay
this like you're maybe like start like
that first
crack in the rose colored glasses is hit
right and up until then nobody had ever
hit the glasses
right i've just been going through life
being like that whole situation was
totally normal because everybody who was
out there with me
acted like it was totally okay and i'm
too embarrassed to tell
almost people in my life who maybe would
tell me that it wasn't
so like the first cracks hit and i'm
like
you know still fine and then just
going through life so that once boom the
usada report comes out
i think it was almost this like oh
like not only do i kind of have this
like you just got
you got like red pills right like you
just went into the matrix all of a
sudden yes
yeah yeah or came out of the matrix and
like who knows maybe had i
not had that like little crack
in the glasses like maybe they wouldn't
have fully shattered i have no idea
i think they would have because like if
you read 270 pages of that report you're
just like
mind blown um recommend it fun times
um but i think that
um when i came out and i shared my story
right
i think first off i thought nobody was
gonna read it
like i'm like my mom's gonna give me a
pity watch and like feel sad that she
watched that thing
and then there's gonna be like a small
contingency of the running community
and i honestly thought that 50
of the people you know again like maybe
10 people watch it
five of those people are like that's sad
one person is like wow that's me
and then the other four are like that
girl's fat she's just slow
but to me that one person
saying okay wow
that is me like would be worth it and i
didn't care how many people were
negative i didn't care
like at all about the response it was
just for that one person
and that it was like a thursday morning
i woke up
and it was everywhere 17 million people
have watched on youtube alone
and lord knows how many on the new york
times website it's insane but i want to
back into this
yeah a little bit because there's a lot
more going on here
um after the
report comes out the the rose-colored
glasses are
cracking a little bit you're coming to
terms with
the reality of this situation and on
some level
you're wrestling with the idea of going
public with it
but the initial thought was i'll share
this on
instagram i'll write a little thing up
then
bringing it back to how we started this
podcast enter
alexi pappas yes who i didn't know
was the puppet master behind the scenes
here yes that put you
with lindsey krause and kind of set in
motion
this whole thing yes yeah and and what
it was was like
when i even first spoke to alexi it was
in that like
very just like i need to
like write i need to like throw stuff
onto paper like
almost like throw this up um bad analogy
that's pretty fast from a crack in the
glasses to like
i feel the need to talk about this now
yes and i think it's because like
there's such a frantic energy and this
like
almost fear that happens in
that moment because i'm gonna say like
that this whole situation has made me
like and this is this is bad this is
something i'm working on with my
therapist
but like less trusting and it's made me
like
more skeptical of authority and it's
made me question
like society's behavior in a way that
i just never had done before
and i think that's really powerful and i
think that's a great thing
but in that moment it's like really
horrifying
to be like oh my god like this
this was condoned this was normalized
people acted like this was okay
and i'm realizing right now how bad this
was
and like who am i kind of in this
big world to like
have figured it out and i think knowing
that i
did it was like
you know 24 hours ago i didn't
and like that person almost scared me
and i was like i need to help them
and obviously i couldn't go back in time
and help myself so how can i pass it
forward to the next person
you know it was like my immediate
reaction and i remember
i pulled my parents aside like
maybe the next day or like really early
on in this and like i had a
you know i was like i have to tell you
everything and like
we did the deep dive and we went like
this was like an hours long conversation
of me just sharing
everything and as like
you know there's obviously a lot of
tears that i can't even get through a
podcast without crying
and at the end like my parents question
was like what are you gonna do
and i said and i don't know i think i'm
gonna start crying
but i was like i don't think
i'm ever going to be a pro runner again
but i love this sport
if nobody's ever gonna sign me nobody's
ever gonna follow me again i said but i
can't live with myself if i don't
share this and if i don't like help that
one person
and i remember like they were so scared
for me
and so proud of me at the same time
and i think for them it was just just
like
like it was almost like this happy proud
and this like you're doing something
bigger than yourself
and again we didn't think anybody would
watch the video
i thought if if anything i'm going to be
very honest when i say this
having so many people watch that
protected me
in a way that i don't know do people
understand
and had that been something where like a
couple thousand people watched it
like the same
negativity from one side of that
conversation
would have been louder and it probably
would have been stronger and you see it
in how
other athletes from that program have
since been treated when they left and
when they
came forward and when they were vocal
and in many ways like
that's what i thought i was going to
experience i mean
cara goucher has gotten death threats um
you know athletes have been called
horrible things
across like websites social media
they've been gaslighted um and i just
i was prepared for that like that was
what i was signing up for
and you know the sport is one in which
again
like what what was done
was really horrible and yet
like a lot of the competitors of these
organizations
don't necessarily turn around and say
like oh wow like
you're really trying to do something
good in the world like let's
you know like support you if anything in
the traditional space
it's much more like no you're not that
fast anymore like whatever
yeah and everybody's running to protect
their own at the same time i mean it is
a david and goliath story
it's not just hey this is mary kane and
she's gonna share
her story you know of how hard it was
this is you basically taking on
nike i mean it's you know that's a very
and you're a young person like that's
very
scary and you still want to have this
career in running
so you're going to become you're risking
becoming persona non-grata in doing this
that takes like an unbelievable amount
of of courage to do that and i
i thank you for saying that and i think
again though it's like the the almost
sad thing
is that yes it was courageous and yes i
was being vulnerable
but that was like pure fear
that was guiding me and it wasn't fear
of repercussions it wasn't
fear of like you know the big bad guy
it was fear that somebody was living a
lie
and and hurting themselves because they
didn't know it
and it was fear for that younger version
of myself it was that fear of that
version of myself from 72 hours before
that drove me and i say that you know
in so much is to say like i think these
issues
are terrifying i think the fact that we
don't
like support and protect people
and treat them as um you know
like these incredible gifts and i say
this like in a very general like we're
outside of sport way
like people are people they're not
products
and when organizations lose sight of
that and take advantage of people
like that goes beyond sport yeah you
know women being taken
advantage of goes beyond sport women
being objectified
this is like the reason 17 million
people watched it
is because it's not just a sports story
and it's not even just a woman's story
this is a when powerful
people abuse and
you know what is power it depends on the
situation
and so there are plenty of people in the
world with power over others
and the idea that you know somebody was
trapped in that
was like you know that's like that fear
guided me
um and so like when people say i was
brave or courageous like i thank them
i appreciate that but like it
this wasn't a moment for me like this
was literally me like
chucking the baton across the room and
being like
save yourself because it's horrifying
when you're in that
and i couldn't get proper treatment
really until i knew like my relationship
with food
pre like even during that new york times
piece
was like weaker now
than it is today and it's because all
the work that i had done
had always been not at the root of the
issue
well that earnestness and that
sensibility comes across
in the video for sure i mean you get
that and i think that's
a big reason why it did end up
connecting with so many people and for
people that haven't seen it
essentially lindsey krause who's been on
the podcast before
you know accomplished runner in her own
right is all about
these issues she's like the perfect
person oh 100 for
you know alexi to say go see this person
i know like you contacted her and she's
like come to the come to the new york
times office right now like
and you're like i thought i was going to
do an instagram post and now you're
making this movie with her
yeah but she really helps craft and
shepherd this message
in a in a mindful intentional way and
the end product of which is is really
palpable
and powerful so you know it's not
surprising to me that so many people
uh have not only seen it but were
impacted by
it and all of this happens really
quickly right so the
the the you know the usada
salazar thing comes out in september
right yeah i wrote like down the
timeline here because it all happens
really quickly
october nike shuts down oregon project
november well then nova so
the nike ceo mark parker steps down was
that before
the video yeah i think so and then uh
yeah and then november 4th wada says it
will investigate each athlete
that trained with salazar by the way i
was never investigated
i was going to ask you i was like what's
the status of that bike i was about to
say like
please investigate me like i don't know
what camera what's going on
because like to me the story seems to
end
with your video kind of and your call
for
third party investigation of nike i
couldn't find any evidence that
there's you know a narrative beyond that
like
it doesn't seem that that's happening
but in any event so november 7th
then your video comes out and then
alberta was safe sport band
maybe like a few weeks after yeah after
that right
temporarily is it still it's still
temporary technically
and he's still obviously in that four
year window
yeah right um
must sheer surprise i would suspect i
mean first of all i can't imagine you
being you the next day
when you your world must have just
exploded right like
it was one of those you must have been
terrified i mean did you even sleep the
night before that this was
coming out knowing that this was gonna
come out super early
and i like did i like i definitely had
such a restless night and again i
thought it was gonna be like
you know super like super small
50 50 negative positive but like
it still was just like i wanted to be
able to see it in the world
and then like never never look again
right that was my thought
i thought i was going to like delete my
instruments have you seen it before have
you seen
had you you've seen that obviously right
beforehand yeah
um and i was able to send it to my mom
and like you know what the
you know the really tragic thing too is
like my
first thought when i watched the video
was i was like i look really fat
like that was literally the first
thought i had and i remember i called my
mom and i was like
i think they're just gonna think i was
the fat girl who didn't do well and
again
it's like that is how recent that's the
disorder though
and that is how like reason i was to
being like that deep in it
and like i'll be honest i still struggle
um but my god like a year and a half
different
just because i was able to like almost
stop treating just the food but treat
the
the ptsd um
but i was able to see it before and that
morning
was insane and um
the craziest thing was i was
being called like my and my parents
house were being called i don't even
know how they were getting my parents
phone number
and like different news outlets wanted
me to like
do exclusives with them and you know
like
two like competing like
news networks were calling me and like
one kind of kept threatening that like
if i didn't do their thing then they
like or if i did
their competitors then they wouldn't
talk to me and i remember
i just yelled at the woman on the phone
and i was like
how dare you i was like i did not
do this to get on your tv show like
i did not do this so that i could be
thrust into this like toxic competitive
world
like i did this to help people if you
don't want to help people
okay but i'm okay one woman laying down
the law
literally i'm like i'm also like crying
yeah
i'm like i'm a one woman pr team my mom
barely knows how to answer my email
like goodbye and i hung up the phone and
they called me an hour later and they're
like okay we will still put you on
and again like i didn't even care like i
this
i thought i was gonna be like deleting
and burning my like social media
accounts like
this was not what i thought there was a
flurry
i mean everybody had a take on this
there's there was so much press
in the days two days after three days
after this thing
yeah and like lindsay kind of warned me
she was like i kind of think this is
to be big and i was just like the only
runners are going to read this
um and so like she was incredible
um and you know at the time i really was
managing all this by myself like i
she was taking she was protecting you
because i reached out to her and i was
like
wow this is crazy i'd love to talk to
mary
and uh and she was like yeah i'm i'm
keeping a lid i'm trying to help her
keep a lid on it right now
she was incredible and what she even did
was she connected me to west felix
who's allison felix's brother and was
like
you know like reached out to wes and was
like allison went through this when she
did the new york times right we have to
contextualize this because this
came out you know it's there's a series
of you know nike
stuff that was all happening around this
time most notably the allison felix
pregnancy thing yes and her brother wes
who like
isn't the most incredible person um
is her agent and ultimately became mine
as well and
he and so lindsey reached out to him and
was like
mary is drowning like she doesn't know
what to do this was very unexpected
like she's handling it as well as she
can but there's only
like you know you're in this weird
position right where you're like
i want to keep telling the story because
i can help more people
but you're also like i have no way to
manage this on my own this is super
overwhelming
and so he called me up and was like just
anything like forward everything along
to me i'm gonna help you sort through it
like this is
just me being a friend because like
we've been there
and like moments like that and
relationships being developed like that
um were just like again something i'd
never experienced
in track because i'm used to being at
the team bonding trip
where i'm being told like you know
you know man up yeah pretty much and now
i have somebody who i've
like met maybe once and was excited
because i took a picture with them
being like hey i'm here to help you like
no strings attached like you're my
friend now let me help
i mean i've never experienced that
before you're just waiting to get
stabbed in the back oh 100 i mean i'm
still sometimes like i feel like turning
around with certain people
like and but alexi is honestly the
person who taught me that you don't have
to
and that there can be camaraderie in
sport and there can be
um this ability to really be a teammate
and what that means
and i think you know i'm still
in so many ways like now
shocked with how beautiful the sport is
and how positive
it can be when you find the right people
well it had to be unbelievably
gratifying and emotional
to see the outpouring of support i can't
tell you from teammates and all these
people who
you know were you know very frank and
saying like you know i kind of knew this
was going on and i wish i'd said
something and i didn't
or i should have or i didn't know
but i should have you know like all of
that like it was pretty
unanimous yes um and you know
from all over the world yes i mean it
was
like i i will remember to this day when
even people like i told the story in the
new york times about this one specific
meat
and how i um didn't race well it was the
meat that i ultimately
afterwards told the sports like an
alberto that i was cutting myself
and i didn't race well
there was a thunderstorm we went under a
tent i
like was yelled at because i clearly
gained five pounds
between this morning and the race time
because i ate bacons and eggs
and so i ran out into the thunderstorm
this was
honestly my most suicidal moment and i
after like after the piece came out
athletes came forward and said i was
there i saw that
i was in the tent i saw what happened
and i'm sorry
and like that
like i would never let that girl run out
by herself and i never will
but it still means a lot that people
said i'm sorry and i was there
and for me it's about
empowering that person and well first
off
never letting that happen in the first
place but if that ever was
to making sure there are 10 people
running after that girl
because she should not have done that
alone
i'm sorry i i haven't talked about it
it's really
you know honestly i mean thank you for
for being so open about it
and i think you know that recognition
is beautiful and it's critical to your
own personal healing
process 100 and i think it's also like
important for me as i'm
going and embarking on this like new
endeavor and creating a team and
um almost like learning
like it's important to learn what not to
do right
that's that's i have a lot of experience
with what not to do
um but i think the other thing is that
as much as that's good
you know you have to learn what to do
and you can't almost
only be coming into this like
beautiful journey of creating a team
that i'm embarking on with like a
cynical
perspective um which i think would be
really
really easy for me to do um if i'm
honest
and so there's so much importance
the all those nike guys team yeah
exactly that's the name of the team
pretty much um it's like really
important for me to like
think about like so many people who've
helped me and so many people who
supported me through that time
like the alexis or people who just like
like the wesses who stepped up and said
like i'm here for you
um because those are the people who i
can lean on and learn from
when creating something beautiful versus
just
kind of creating something out of a fear
of what was
right you know when you when you look on
the past
it can't ever be like i'm just trying to
rewrite my own story
it's how can i really make something
good going forward
um and so that's why i do think although
obviously i've cried multiple times it's
it's healthy to talk about and it's
important to talk about
um especially when i just held this in
for so long
and and you still look back on that you
know
moment of me running out into like the
thunderstorm
which is so dramatic but literally what
happened
as being this like almost
example of how weak i was you know
and like that was the narrative the
narrative was
in my head because this is what was told
to me like
you're a head case this is your fault
you're the one failing yourself and
for so long that's how i kind of
remembered it
and to suddenly take a step back and
look at it
almost from the eyes of everybody but me
it's suddenly wow that's horrible that
that happened
and how can i make sure it never does
again
yeah it also wasn't that long ago i mean
the pandemic
anything pre pandemic feels like you
know 100 years ago
but we're talking about the end of 2019
like when you
came out with this and on a personal
level you can't be a phoenix without the
fire
like you gotta burn right and
on a on a you know a broader level
in terms of like running in general what
an incredible opportunity because you're
so
uniquely situated with your experience
and the level of exposure that this
story has garnered
that you're now perfectly situated
to re-imagine what the future of running
can look like for
girls and women going forward and you've
taken that you're running with it
you've got the tracksmith partnership
you've got
atlanta i said it correctly that's all
happening
and it's really inspiring and this has
all happened
in a pretty compressed period of time i
mean i know maybe it seems like
not to you but it sounds like it to me
like in the grand scheme of things and
you're so young
and you have so much running ahead of
you and you have so much mentorship
ahead of you like it's truly inspiring
no and i i really appreciate you saying
that and you know as i said those
probably like six weeks between the
usada report and when the new york times
piece came out
felt like the longest six weeks of my
life
and i think i always remember that when
ever i feel like oh gosh like you know
things aren't happening quick enough or
i want to be here by x date and
you know almost our um i think or at
least my predisposition
to like push push push um i always look
back and i'm like that was only six
weeks
and so in the scheme of things it has
been a really really short time
um which is also why i'm you know i'm
continuing to try to learn
you know i i think one thing that i do
sometimes feel a little uncomfortable
with
is that um you know we're all flawed
individuals
right and so even me kind of taking this
step as a mentor and as an advocate
i have to always be very conscious of my
own place in the world
and how i can be educating myself and
learning new things and
kind of taking that next step
because for as much as i lived my
experience
there's so many other like moments
people can go through
that i will never experience and i will
never know
and to take that level of learning and
and kind of spread this in a way that's
more inclusive
and and not just my story um can only
happen
if i'm constantly trying to better
myself
which is why even with this program that
i'm creating and the service side of it
like
we're going to create extensive
extensive
educational standards for all the
mentors
because you can't just expect like a
young
well somebody of any age to be ready to
kind of
teach right like you have to learn
before you can teach
right i think you're going to be really
successful with this because
based on what you just said there's an
there's a a
a real appreciation for humility
and the level of empathy that you're
able to bring to it like it just
it feels you know it's such a heart
heart-centered thing for you
and i could tell that you've thought it
completely through so i'm excited to see
what it looks like yeah thank you i i
can't wait for this journey and i know
everything's gonna keep going quick and
feeling like it's taking forever but the
more that i can stay in the present and
enjoy that moment
um and always be proud of like where i
am today
um as much as proud of what i hope to
long-term accomplish
um you know i think that's one thing
that i'm really working on and and i
also
you know will kind of share it to
anybody else who's maybe diving into
like their next steps or
a big endeavor for them is to like
appreciate the day-to-day and be proud
of those like
little moments and those little um steps
in the right direction because
it does it does go quick when you look
back at least even if not in the moment
yeah yeah yeah we got to wrap this up in
a couple minutes but there's a couple
more things i want to
touch on before i release you to your
life um
i think another reason why the video
really worked
was that it wasn't just you telling your
story
you were like this is this is this is
what happened to me
but what you need to understand is that
there's a systemic problem and that
needs to change nike needs to change
nike's too powerful
and the investigation that had been
launched
really had nothing to do with the way
that you were treated or this kind of
toxic culture it was all about the
doping thing right
and nike ultimately is going to do what
nike needs to do to protect its brand
so it's going to basically
you know give lip service to this sweep
under the rug whatever they can get away
with and
move on and you were the one at the
outset calling for
a third party to conduct this
investigation like okay so they're going
to self-police themselves here like what
is that
you know like what does that actually
mean like obviously you know nothing's
going to happen so
my sense is that that didn't happen
there is no third party
investigating is there any update like i
just wanted to know what is the
2021 status update on what's
happened there um so i think uh
first off there was an internal
investigation
and i only know this because like one
reporter
was told that and i was reached out
for comment because i guess there was
nothing released
besides nothing public there wasn't like
a public dossier or something
here's what happened the only thing that
was like shared with this
journalist um erin strout from women's
running
was that um they were going to maybe
like
invest more in women
and like
stuff like that right so like super
vague i can't even remember what it was
yeah um and you know
at the time i remember being asked for
comment and i was like hey
anytime any movement is going towards
like
empowering women that's great sure and
it's
it's tricky and complicated because you
look at serena williams and
and what they've done with her and it's
unbelievable right
so it makes it it's like okay and then
you tell your story
and i don't know what to think yes well
i think part of it is that like
we also have no idea behind closed doors
what was happening
right it's a company made up of people
you know right yeah
and those individuals turn over like
tried to protest within nike there were
like 100 people that protested right
yeah right
after that and like people were
threatened to be fired if they like walk
near the alberto salazar building
that's kind of scary um is it still
called the alberto salazar building yep
the new hayward field there's a memorial
to him
there's like a big picture at a stadium
that i'll probably have to run it
multiple times over the course of my
career
oh my god and that was built after it
was only like
recently finished like a couple months
ago that's right they just redid it
and they did like a reboot so like i
think for me it's one of those things
where
as you know as you've seen through the
documentation i've sent you for this
my own like business that i'm trying to
start um
i don't like using buzzwords and i try
to avoid it at all cost
so if i say like i'm trying to
empower women that means nothing to me
right this is actually what i'm gonna do
and i'm gonna outlay
steps a b c where we're gonna go how
we're gonna support it
and you know what if i don't have an
answer yet that's always okay
but then say i'm gonna have to lean on
these partners and these experts and
take these
next steps and so i think the thing
the big maybe like takeaways if you're
a multi-billion dollar organization is
like
actually care and actually figure out
like okay if we're gonna do something
what are we gonna do
and how are we gonna do it and and you
know don't just keep coming out with ads
that you know even recently support
like women like women who are pregnant
and
are athletes right because i watch that
and i think
you're you've never acknowledged how you
treated
kara alicia allison there's never been
any sort of
like hey we did wrong and i think
i have always felt that leaders are not
people who do everything right
leaders are people who are always trying
to better themselves
always know they have places to learn
and can acknowledge that they're going
to fail sometimes
and in those moments can step
up and say i'm sorry and this is how i'm
going
to change going forward sure they take
responsibility
yeah i see it as like look you can try
to
whitewash this and put out a bunch of
marketing campaigns and the the truth is
the average public isn't paying
attention to this no of course
it's not is it you how concerned are
they really
but ultimately it seems to me in their
long-term growth interest
to really reckon with this the amount of
goodwill
that they would be able to engender if
they if if
the new ceo said i'm getting to the
bottom of this
i'm taking it you know super seriously
and they really did
like do a top to bottom revamp on how
they're dealing with all of these issues
the amount of storytelling alone that
they could do out of that
would create you know a bulletproof
brand going forward
and they have the the balance sheet to
be able to
make that happen yeah i mean i remember
when the
first kind of comments from nike came
out after my piece
first time i never thought they were
going to comment because i never thought
it was going to be big enough
um but the fact that it was immediately
like blaming and trying to undermine the
story like
to me it was just horrifying but the
thing is like so alberta backfired badly
though
yes and i mean alberto is still um
i think his like kind of usada appeal
has been i think it's complete at this
point i'm not sure
as of when the podcast released whether
or not there'll be any sort of findings
um we're still waiting on the final safe
sport ruling about like
whether this is an indefinite ban for
him via
safe sport um so there's still two
different like investigations that like
are
yet to be like fully determined um
but the thing is that like his whole
like legal like pursuit with usada and
with safesport
is being backed by nike and they've been
very public that they're supporting him
in his appeals um and i think that's one
of those moments where you're just like
you know how can you not just listen to
my story
but listen to kara's and amy owner
begley and
all of these other athletes who have
come forward and said
this happened to them and
like still try to shut them down
um and i think when you live in a world
where um you know
like there's that amount of power and
there's that much of a will
to take away an athlete's voice um
it makes me want to live in a world
where you're empowering those athletes
and giving them voice
um and that's that's really my goal
is i want the sport to be better once i
leave it
i want athletes to be more empowered i
want them to be protected i want them to
be safe i want them to be healthy
um and i think you know when i was young
i always wanted to be the greatest
professional athlete in the world
and the truth is i still want that um
but i think my definition of greatness
has changed
and i realize that if i had won
all of the races i ever wanted to win um
but i never stood for anything that's
not great
like to me that's to me that's kind of
lame
and um you know if i end my career
having
really changed the sport in a positive
way um
like that's greatness yeah and so that's
why it's crazy how that works right
because you would have suspected that um
the way for you to have the biggest
impact is to go win a bunch of gold
medals or set world records or what have
you
and maybe that'll still happen hopefully
you're interested in where you're
running is right now
um but completely
detached irrespective of that because of
all of these things you're now in a
position to have
a real permanent meaningful substantive
impact on the future of
girls and women's athletics that never
would have happened
had you not endured the things that you
went through
yeah and i think you know the the thing
that's hard for me sometimes
is that like the dream i had as a young
had had as a young athlete of like
being a professional um and i used to be
a swimmer too
so like i you know used to keep that a
little vague like which way we'd go i
know
it cropped up here and there exactly i
know um
you know well you're running 547 miles
in sixth grade
yeah i was still swimming that was my
primary sport
don't know how to run so yeah there's
something weird there
i i heck i see triathlon in your future
yeah we'll see we'll see okay um but i
um i think like the hardest thing can
sometimes be is that like
the dream i had can now never happen
right where the dream was to be a
professional athlete
and to train full-time and to you know
be the lebron james the serena williams
the
um insert any of the top athletes in the
world the usain bolts
right and the truth is
even if i win the olympics
i can't be that person like that dream
was taken away from me
because i'm not
a professional athlete on paper
and the thing is it's been this like
really
interesting reworking of like how do you
let one dream die
and let another one blossom and i think
that's kind of what this last year and a
half
has been for me is like accepting
like i can do something different and
still love it
and still be proud of it um and that's
been
kind of an interesting i would say
journey of realizing that like
you know like how a dream is lived
has to sometimes change
beautifully put i think that's a good
place to
put a pin on it yeah thank you um
thank you that was really powerful i
appreciate you being so open
and honest with me about all of that no
and thank you for giving me the space to
cry
to like at times are you kidding me i
love it when peter it's been a long time
since somebody's cried on the podcast
you might be the first person to cry in
the new studio so you'll always have
that i've christened it with my tears
yeah uh if i come to new york will you
go running with me
and lindsey krauss can we go running
together oh my god that'd be amazing you
guys have to run really slow though
you have to slow down a lot sounds great
to me i don't know um
that would be super fun and uh don't
steal
alexis alexie's my bff she's my neighbor
now so just
boundaries you're going over to her
house right now right really just
understand
that i'm i have dibs i i think i've
known her longer i think i will it
doesn't matter
she lives here now i'm being protective
i know
i think long term like how do we get her
to new york though you know
i'm like putting i like her down the
street from me i don't want her to go to
new york
maybe you do put her on your board yeah
true true
very true um awesome well i look forward
to
going running with you and talking more
so thanks how can people find out more
about atlanta
you you're easy to find on the internet
but where do you want to direct people
yep um social media is gonna always be
the way to go like my personal account
is run mary kane and then atlanta also
has their own
instagram cool at atlanta
atlanta i'm never going to figure that
out
at atlanta nyc yeah cool all right
thank you peace plants running
[Music]
you